the secret world
used by criminals to buy and sell drugs
guns sex just about
anything you can imagine it's equivalent
to walking in the back alleys at night
and looking for your drug dealer
you're just doing it from the comfort of
your home it's essentially the ebay of
the underworld
once you're there in the dark web it is
alarming what's being bought and sold
i mean i actually spent most of my
teenage years joshing around on internet
forums
so it's actually kind of surprising that
i've yet to try going on the dark web
may as well try today why not
you ready for this jack yeah you could
buy some like maybe some black market
hair product
because you definitely definitely don't
use enough of it you should definitely
buy a gun because you never know
and i thought you go buy a dirty gun
right
but you just make sure you don't get
caught with it and just throw it away
don't buy a gun whether it's dirty or
not
don't buy anything for the dark web
we're gonna go meet with jake who is the
head of the equipment room
he is the head right okay good from what
jake's told me he's actually very
experienced and knowledgeable about the
dark web so i'm thinking
he's probably a good launching pad for
us to start with
jake all right we're coming on in
i guess it was when i got into
cryptocurrency i realized that you
needed cryptocurrency buy things in the
dark web and then i just thought to
myself
i'm going to check out the dark web so
you can use cryptocurrency to buy itself
on the dock you can only buy things with
cryptocurrency in the dark web you can
only buy stuff with you you can't buy
things with like us dollar and stuff
like you're not going to like send a
wire transfer or use like venmo or
paypal
to buy drugs because that leaves a paper
trail do they just like ship it
to your house like what do you do my
understanding is they do just ship it to
your house but they have stealth
packaging
ways like that i don't know like they'll
ship drugs with different things that'll
mask the scent or that you won't see it
in an x-ray or something like that
it's mostly about blocking the smells
and blocking the scents from coming out
well i guess if you're buying you know a
pound of coke
you know you kind of want it to be a
mask does cocaine have a smell jack
i wouldn't know we're not going to give
too many details away in case there are
any
criminals watching this but how easy
would you say it actually is for like
the average person to get on the dark
web if they really wanted to
it's extremely easy you can't access the
dark web through
any old browser you can't use chrome
safari anything like that you have to
use these special privacy-centric
browsers to do it this is a useful
browser even if you're not doing illegal
things with it but it's more useful
when you're doing legal things because
it makes it safer
fantastic i feel like max on catfish
right now you're a catfishing one jack
have you ever been catfished all right
so we are going to go ahead and
use one of these links that i have
saved for this how did i get these well
i can't really say all right so we're on
we can get digital goods drugs drug
paraphernalia services
or other what do you want to check out
[Music]
bear with me my thinking is that after
jake sketched me out a little bit about
this whole thing
if we do this somewhere a little bit
more isolated less likely to get traced
all right are we getting into a van
hello
my body's ready wait my body's not ready
whoa
everyone oh god this is uh
quite the setup dude i feel like i'm
about to get kidnapped i'm
going through some ptsd right now oh you
[ __ ]
oh what do you guys know about the dark
web
that's where scary legal stuff happens
on the internet right i didn't even
think it was possible
or legal to access it my brother used to
go there he said you could find drugs
body parts and hitmen
i don't approve does anyone actually
have like a
tape on them or something because we're
all supposed to cover our webcam damn
can they see us nowhere kelsey you got
evan and i here you know
we'll get we'll get kidnapped first wait
what okay
we got crystal meth shards holy [ __ ]
uh oxycodone cocaine oh my god
56 grams wait this is wild
dissociatives you have so you can go to
different categories
of drugs a half gram of crystal meth
goes for
95 bucks this is all just here
to be purchased by anyone yeah it's like
amazon
for drugs you can buy steroids here i
mean
you can also buy those i know somebody
who sells them
you guys are both very fit healthy
people you should look at the steroids
section maybe
steroids are you trying to continue
i'm just saying just like on amazon they
have a rating it's like this guy here
4.98 out of five i mean that's pretty
good
he's got the good drugs that's good you
always need to have a system to know if
you're buying from a good
business person oh they give you ratings
too like an uber rating
that's better than my uber rating yours
would probably be like a perfect
like 10 out of 10 uber rating so like
personable
everyone loves arya i like how i said it
like an
insult you sound like you're insulting
me most trusted seller on ds so far
really top-notch product as
advertised okay so if you need coke this
is the guy the stealth was great
merchant is solid good job
order was they sound like really like
pleasant people
183 reviews some of them as
there's first of all there's like at
least 11 or 12 of them that have
happened in the past three days
dude this is mind-blowing i did not
think that the interface would be so
pleasant i will say i appreciate that
there's no ads
no pop-ups no pop-ups thousand-dollar
for
visa oh this is a bank logo so you get
someone's bank login is that what it's
basically saying
yes yeah because of data breaches where
that stuff leaks out
there are so many millions of different
people's information that's leaked out
that it's very cheap to buy usually buy
them in big bulk uh
packages from what i get wow you can buy
someone's social security number right
there
are you oh my god whose social security
is that we need to inform who's this
person
that's probably mine oh god all right
i'm gonna click on
the erotica button oh that's that is
porn
oh that's a lot a lot of all right let's
move away you could probably buy a lot
of
used underwear here which you don't have
to go to the dark web really for that
are you very familiar with
yeah i've made a video about it check it
out
so for 10 bucks you can get a lifetime
porn premium account and that is a woman
that's naked
she is that seems pretty cheap well i
guess that's the the lure right
you're like okay pay me i'll give you a
lifetime account yeah because in real
life that's 36.99 per month
i'm sorry i've known or so i've been
told you can buy a spotify account
lifetime you know what i'm gonna buy in
the black market
spotify account see here's the thing
yeah my brother also did mention to me
the dark web is not so dark all the time
you could buy literature you could buy
art
movies there's a lot of other stuff and
if you want to buy a book and a little
bit of drugs to go with it
so be it there's the dark dark web stuff
but like new york times has a
website on the dark web it's not just
for this kind of stuff
there's uh so it's not all like bad it's
not all bad
i think it's a lot more user friendly
than i expected and a lot less scary
it's like a weird look into what people
desire
i thought it was going to be all like
how to make a bomb sex trafficking
it's a lot more drugs and fraud with
money i mean
you can literally do anything and
understand truly
that's terrifying that's pretty that's
pretty scary it is interesting to see
like that this is what's kind of like on
the surface level of it
right and if this is just what the
uninitiated can find
very easily i'm sure there has to be
more uh
underneath what a great day this has
been you know thanks aria
i've been curious about being in one of
your videos and now i don't know
[Music]
like what you see no